in your wildest dreams you think you'd
be one of 56 SMP well sending our
wildest dreams but I don't think Alda
allowed myself to forecast that as it
extraordinary a performance and
unparalleled I can't actually think of
her in a democratic electoral system a
landslide like it it's an amazing
achievement necklace dungeons
achievement for her performance during
the election campaign but the
achievement of all these SMP activists
that the lentil bread for the country
who made such a victory possible and
there's a little bit of you think if I'd
have hung on in there is First Minister
and leader this could have been all my
glory and you happy that Nicolas
sturgeons taking the plaudits she's not
even an MP no either fear she Ligurian
my timeless as First Minister I mean in
2000 why we - to get 45 46 % the vote
and that then was seen as a huge
landslide in an absolute majority in a
PR system this time necklace got over
50% of the vote which is even more
amazing but nothing has its time and if
I had my time as First Minister and of
course the political opportunity that
the SNP has seized really depended on
having that change of that leadership
because somebody has to take pre get be
as we got beat in the referendum some
just to take responsibility that's the
right thing to do
and therefore we cleared the ground in
order to make this make this latest
advance